yeah you know I can I can only really
speak best to a distinction between
American women and French women because
I've lived in France a lot and and
that's the world that I'm immersed in
when I'm not living here in New York and
a lot of these differences will sound
cliche but I think they really hold true
and the first and biggest difference
that my French friends always point out
to me is that French women shop less and
better than American women so French
women will buy something that's very
high-quality one very nice little
tailored black jacket one very elegant
little pair of ballerina flats and an
American and I include myself
unfortunately in this category I like
the nice tailored jacket and I like the
beautiful ballerina flats but I'll also
pop into H&M and buy eight t-shirts in
different colors just because they're
there and I can and they're cheap and it
might be fun to introduce them into my
wardrobe someday French women as a
result have closets that are a lot less
cluttered generally than their American
counterparts French women also repeat
what they wear a lot more a French woman
would much rather be seen in the same
little black dress or in the same little
tailored blue jacket or the same pair of
shoes over and over again and have that
be her uniform and know that she looks
great and that it's perfectly fitted to
her body and that it's the highest
quality I think there is an American
mentality of reckless consumerism which
is and I remember the first year that I
was a professor I was guilty of this at
my first year as a professor it was 1998
and I was teaching at the University of
Pennsylvania and I decided that I would
never wear the same outfit to class
twice in part because I was paranoid
that my students would notice and that
it would become distracting but in fact
the opposite was true and my students
wrote comments about favorite outfits
favorite pairs of shoes on my teacher
evaluations at the end of term and and
that was a little embarrassing but what
that what that showed was a very
American approach which is that more is
always better but different is always
better I think a second difference
that's again a stereotype but I've found
it to be true between American and
French women is that French women will
spend much more money on what they're
wearing underneath their clothes that on
their clothes themselves and French
friends spend so much money on beautiful
lingerie and whenever I'm in Paris I I
try to splurge and buy one or two pieces
but my mentality is always well nobody
or maybe one person is going to see it
besides me if I'm lucky and and
otherwise I'd like to be seen by as many
people as possible with my very chic
outerwear but but French women have that
real cult of sensuality that real cult
of seduction that's very much in their
blood I think and that translates into a
much bigger lingerie industry or much
bigger lingerie sales over there and it
it means that if you're in Paris for
instance and your luggage is lost and
you think oh I'll just go into some kind
of Kmart esque department store to buy
cheap cotton underwear even a pair of
cheap cotton underwear is like $50 in
the Paris equivalent of Kmart because
it's every everything that you put on as
an undergarment is viewed as worthy and
as viewed as kind of a special luxury so
you can't have cheap underwear ratty
underwear cheap old bras that doesn't
really exist and then I would say the
third thing and this is where maybe I'm
more in favor of the American aspect of
things in the French aspect of things is
I've noticed at least that there's a
much stronger culture of conformity in
France than there is in America at the
level of female dress most of the
American women I know are willing to
experiment to a greater or lesser degree
and are willing to wear something a
little wacky or willing to wear bright
red shoes or a hot pink sweater in
France it's very very very still
implicitly codified I mean kind of like
that the court of Versailles I remember
one day I had bought this beautiful hot
pink eve-san long cape at a secondhand
store somewhere in Paris and I had to
ride the Metro to get back to my
apartment on the left bank and I was
proudly wearing my I'd thrown it on
because it was heavy in the bag and I
was wearing this beautiful hot pink
eve-san long cape from the 60s and I got
in the metro and within five minutes I
was incredibly uncomfortable because
every other woman on the train was
wearing either a navy blue a tan or a
dark green quilted barn jacket they were
all wearing the barn jacket and it when
they all looked great and they all had
the little Hermes scarf or Hermes
equivalent scarf tied around their necks
and they all have the neat little skirt
but it was astonishing both how
homogeneous the rest of the crowd was
and how much like a sore thumb I stuck
out a stuck out at that moment
and so in that sense I I'm more
comfortable in America because there's a
lot more room for innovation and
experimentation here than there is in
France where it really is still a
culture of conformity and judgment and
you really are a freak if you're not
falling into line with what everybody
else is wearing in a particular moment